remembering george floyd the man whose
death awakened a movement to upend our
nation's legacy of racism
was laid to rest yesterday after a
powerful ceremony in houston
hundreds attended george floyd's funeral
more than two weeks after he was killed
in a confrontation
with minneapolis police seen around the
world
tony yeah and the world watched as his
body was then taken in a horse-drawn
hearse to his final resting place
beside his mother cbs this morning
saturday co-host michelle miller covered
the funeral in houston
michelle good morning this was a chance
for floyd's family to speak out
what do they have to say
good morning after an emotional service
at the fountain of praise church
right behind me george floyd's family
said the memorial does not mark the end
of his life
but the beginning of a new chapter the
chapter where floyd could change
the world the world knows
george floyd i know perry jr
george perry floyd was honored in a
celebration of life service
in his hometown of houston texas but in
the tradition of the african-american
church
this will be a homegoing celebration
floyd's family shared stories about the
man the world did not get to see
he was a pesky little rascal
[Laughter]
but we all loved him i thank god for
giving me
give me my own personal superman but
they also said they will continue their
mission in his name
but right now i want justice for my
brother
my big brother and i can breathe as long
as i'm breathing
justice will be served for a period
it was a four-hour memorial service
filled with music
art and messages
one message came creatively when floyd's
likeness was painted
as an anthem for the civil rights
movement was belted out
floyd sparked change in his own hometown
mayor sylvester turner says he is
signing an executive order
which bans choke holds within houston in
this city
we will require de-escalation
in this city you have to give a warning
before you shoot
and we'll put george's name in history
the reverend al sharpton delivered a
stirring eulogy
god took the rejected stone
and made him the cornerstone of a
movement that's going to change the
whole wide world
sharpton also called on sports leagues
to be accountable
oh it's nice to see some people change
their mind the
head of the nfl said yeah
maybe we was wrong well don't apologize
give colin kaepernick a job back
at the end of the service a horse-drawn
hearse took floyd
to his final resting place where he is
buried
next to his mother the person he cried
out for
during his last moments all i think
about is when he was yelling for mama
and i know how mama is she's just right
there she got her hand
wide open
the families of brianna taylor ahmad
arbury eric garner
michael brown and trayvon martin showed
their support
by being here the last few days showing
the floyd family they are not alone in
this struggle
think of them as members of the
fraternal order of families
who know what it is like to lose a loved
one to violence
floyd's brother is expected to testify
today at a congressional hearing on
police reforms
in washington that is a big day for him
for this family for
this city anthony
it is michelle thank you